do you think that should that that
Donald Trump will not accept the
election results and are you prepared to
to follow him should he not accept those
election results on election night well
Donald Trump made it clear in his first
debate and I've made it clear that will
accept the will of the American people
but I think Donald Trump's going to win
we've got a brand new poll out today
from investors business daily that that
has this up a percentage point I see
tremendous momentum all across the
country but what Donald Trump and I are
saying is that that with all due respect
the American people see the obvious bias
among many in the national media
opposing Donald Trump's campaign for
president and frankly the the rigged
system in the media is also is a genuine
concern to millions of Americans and
calling that out i think i think is fair
as open and and and that along with the
need for every American to participate
in ensuring the integrity of the vote
voter fraud is real it's occurred
throughout our history we have a way to
ensure that what however Democrats
Republicans or independents vote that
everyone's vote counts and that's by
respectfully participating the electoral
and I know you I know you're busy so
just wondering question to do that just
one more question for you but they're
also has been a lot of talk and we do
have a poll that shows you guys nine
point down and I want to make that clear
as well because other there's a plethora
of bowls out there we live in the count
but there's there's also a pull out
there that shows your favorite ability
rating is actually 10 percentage points
higher than Donald Trump's and I'm
wondering that regardless of the
election outcome should he win should he
lose what role do you have governor in
unifying the Republican Party and in the
future of the Republican Party because
whether you look at you taller whether
you look elsewhere this is a party
that's divided what's your role I
couldn't be more honored to have the
opportunity to run and serve with the
next president of the United States of
America you know I accepted this
invitation because I believe Donald
Trump has the right ideas and he has the
right leadership to really bring America
back to strengthen America at home and
abroad and as vice president of the
United States it would be my ambition to
work with my former colleagues in the
Congress to work with governors around
the country and
with people all across America to
implement Donald Trump's vision to make
America should he lose what your role
Donald Trump's going to be elected
president will leave its their governor
Pence thank you for the time okay